je suis moi-même 2 millions section des
résultats provisoires contesti est un
pays dans le chaos
l'annoncé de la victoire de mohamed
bazoum aux élections présidentielle par
la commission électorale n'est pas
acceptée le candidat d'opposition
mahamane ousmane a revendiqué avoir
remporté le scrutin
la combinaison des états des pv en
procession dédiée aux mobiles gagnant
avec 52% des x 70 où le candidat du
pouvoir
des annonces qui contredisent les
résultats provisoires et qui font planer
un doute sur la légitimité des élections
selon mahamane ousmane la victoire de
son adversaire fidèles du président
sortant mamadou issoufou n'est pas
justifiée
plus encore selon le candidat
d'opposition les chiffres prouvent une
véritable corruption a donné l exemple
la construction des tesnières ou un taux
de participation de 5 3% a été reporté
avec un score de 90 1 % en faveur du
candidat du pouvoir d'un ses hommes
mon délire on était content sous la
menace d'armes à feu a signé les pays
sans aucune possibilité de porter les
eaux ce match et cette prise de parole
diffusé mercredi matin et dont les
chiffres n'ont pas été authentifiées a
été suivie par plusieurs manifestations
dans le pays
c'était notamment le cas dans la
capitale niamey une station service a
été vandalisée et des affrontements
entre protestataires et forces de
l'ordre ont également éclaté le tda
qu'on appelle à un produit c'est la rade
les dacquois est pas fini
près des positions c'est à cause de ça
on en sortie en sortie pou fé d'eads à
se pousser là parce qu'on voit pas le
bâton avait pas de l'accès au réseau
internet a quant à lui été
considérablement réduits dont les villes
de niamey et zinder sans explication
apparente
et si pour le moment les résultats des
élections présidentielles ne sont que
provisoires
l'objectif initial est loin d'être
atteint en effet c'est la première fois
depuis 60 ans qu'un président va
succéder à un autre président élu
démocratiquement
reste à savoir qui de mohamed bazoum ou
de mahamane ousmane récupérera la tête
du niger et pourra rassembler un pays
qui semble divisée c'est désormais à la
cour constitutionnelle de trancher